the entire machine is focused on
DeSantis and lying about every single
thing that is happening down here in
Florida so diversity higher Corinne
Jean-Pierre she is our first black
lesbian press secretary she is
completely unqualified she makes Jen
saki look talented which that is a
talent in and of itself here she is
lying about what DeSantis is doing with
kids and parents shocker I know
videotape can you respond to governor on
sandus in Iowa today who said Florida is
where woke goes to die
so here's what I have to say
when Republicans
extreme Republicans these Mega
Republicans
don't agree
um with an issue or with policy they
don't bring forth something that's going
to either
have a a good faith conversation they go
to this conversation of woke
but that is not actually policy
but what they what that turns into is
hate what it turns into is Despicable
policy
um and it's just not the way we're going
to move forward
this is not protecting freedoms this is
not having a good faith conversation on
how we can move the country forward this
is about attacking we're talking about
attacking young kids and their parents
because of how they view themselves
no one it's simply not happening you
Corinne Jean-Pierre could come to
Florida you probably vacation on Miami
Beach like the rest of the Democrats
and no one will care about you or your
lesbian wife they might Point At You and
go my God that's Corrine Jean-Pierre
she's a pretty terrible press secretary
but nobody's gonna stop you from going
anywhere because you're black or because
you're a lesbian it's just utter
nonsense and that she dares says that
she's the one that wants to have good
the Democrats yes the Democrats want to
have good faith conversations and that
when you say woke it doesn't translate
into good policy yes it does we're doing
it right here that's why even liberals
bananas California Liberals are moving
to Florida 1200 a day and is it not
Karin Jean-Pierre the Biden Department
of Justice that was trying to treat
parents as domestic terrorists when they
got upset that random School teachers
were talking to their kids about
sexuality and gender and their genitals
yeah that's what the Biden
Administration was doing uh wasn't it
the Biden Administration that forced
parents and kids to take take a fake
vaccine and get booster shots and put on
masks and kick them out of schools and
everything else and now we are seeing
all the results of that whether it is
vaccine injuries or whether it is
delayed speech with kids or social
problems or anxiety or whatever else
yeah I think you know I'm right Corinne
Jean-Pierre I'm just trying to have a
good faith argument with you
[Music]